previously on raft there's been a new
update now the game's finished so we're
starting over again because our files
are all really growing don't tell them
things
i died on the edge of the wrap this is
the worst start we've ever had are we
captainly for now until we hold a vote
and then every uh every episode we do
this we'll vote for a new cap
how do we earn captain points maybe i
should get the random number generator
out okay i'm gonna spin the wheel
mark all right i'm rolling the number of
points i get
oh nine
captain points for me baby
wait the shark's dead eat it kill it oh
is it time to spin the wheel of captain
it's me
i'm shocked
with bob at six points weighted 11
points and me at
14 points okay i
will be captain in the next
hour
of this adventure
so
until then which is now
i am not the captain now we're going to
build the now until then do i get a hat
i want a hat sure whatever hat you can
find you can wear but i'm going to go
get a hat good deal what does the
captain actually even do in this
i think he's gone all right well what
does the captain actually do i
i
i don't think we don't think we need to
listen to him oh it's like an honorary
title i think yeah i think he can do
what he wants and pretend to be captain
and say stuff and we'll just do what we
were doing anyway actually it needs to
yeah we'll just do what needs to be done
anyway
i have found my hat
yes it's it's my unis honest uh top hat
that doesn't sound like a thing a
captain would wear i mean it's the ol
it's the only hat i had i also had a
knight's helm but i don't think that
would have worked that sounds a little
bit more captainy to me hey i'm the
captain here i decide what the captain's
at and what's not sure i'm gonna give
points i'm gonna give captain points to
wade
uh he gets three points for not sassing
the captain right out of the gate oh
hell yeah there you go wade you deserve
it you deserve it sure yeah thank you
super fairy it is fair it is fair
absolutely fair is fair fair is fair and
as my first decree of captain i need a
sale uh okay how can i call myself a
captain if i don't have a sale
i don't have any of the things that we
need for sale so all right well looks
like we you've got a job to do
hey i built the sale
okay yes did you
i did excellent work
there you go
that's five points for away
the captain circus somebody drank all
the water and i'm dying if there's oh
sorry uh i
was watering the plants uh would you
like a beet they don't give water
no no i'll just wait i think we're about
to be under attack captain
uh
fight the shark
uh um
wait did you fight the shark
i did it's gone my god that's two points
excellent work
[Music]
like thing full of food for everybody
and you're
welcome to eat it um i don't really
asking for points or anything for it but
i'm just this is
that sale
quality craftsmanship
thank you for saving me yes my my hat is
really impeding the ability for my
headphones to stay on
i really struggle in here but it's fine
the captain will bear this burden guys i
learned a drinking glass and advanced
career fire for us so
not to mention i did all the research
for the metal ingots
that's three points for bob very
very good
you did put your stand in there work for
okay oh there's a shark here if anyone's
hungry
yeah i made cook shark you're welcome
what no no hold on now all right that's
a good three points for you you are the
cook after all i get credit for cooking
activities i mean i killed the sharks
that you're eating and that was in the
last episode
hoarder captain yes
order captain i've brought you a potato
sir oh excellent potato gathering that's
a one point for the potatoes yes
excellent great good points i think
someone's going to get the watermelon i
don't like the way that you're saying
good points but i'll take it i guess
they are good points
uh
hey wade that was mine
you dare i go for you here no no no here
how many points for that
ah it's disappointing
all of the water and didn't refill it
happened i'm refilling the water
purifiers i've not gotten water in a
while
empty your presence for your captainship
i don't know who emptied it uh captain i
found this package for you you found
this package i have six packages in my
inventory you gave me six packs i gave
you
work
foreign
six points for bob for six packs
well you're welcome captain i'm just i
live to serve captain here's another
package
for me captain i'd like to raise a
formal complaint stealing we need to
have a uh captain whether it's a fury
session
court whatever it is what they call it
whatever
it's called
parlay we're having a parlay shouldn't i
get bonus points for stealing
uh not from your fellow pirates yeah
that entirely depends on if we're a
pirate operation yeah i feel like you
don't steal from your bros
you steal
from the hose on other ships from your
hose and the classic snapping pirate
saying
bros before hoes that is classic
okay so you know as everyone knows
everyone on other ships whoever threw
that their mom's a hoe
hmm
this is
really profound evidence
i i will not give points for this but i
will award the watermelon to the winner
which is bob you've won this uh i'm
honored captain thank you fine god's
done
i'm dead
i am vine god
look at this cats and i just want to say
that i'm fishing
and smelting and conducting scientific
research is wonderful all
uh and watch watch this captain i'm
learning how to make a bottle for
learning how to make a cooking pot oh
a sweet net
whoa
oh
quickly are my team turns on me hey wait
if you want to succeed you gotta exceed
but bob you get through every part of
this boat you're standing on i built all
right
you're your beets and potatoes are ready
to harvest ah thank you for the
notifications that is uh
at one point for the uh be making
captain aware of things on the ship very
you may have harvested
constructed the raft but i repaired most
of it myself anyway so
who really gets credit for that i also
disagree with that
i've been killing sharks and repairing
this boat from the start
sure
your statement
killing this shark oh i'm sorry i was
busy harvesting there you're trying to
keep up with the points i i shall oh
present from me i think the captain
should get some captain who drank all
the water and didn't refill it i'm dying
i
i have been refilling it it might have
been me but who knows is a mystery
captain
how did you do this to me
i've got you a throne that's worth three
points if ever there was one that
doesn't seem very important i have to be
we're we're floating on the floor oh
captain i'm floating on the world's
outhouse what what would we possibly
need a storage container for well we
could just
flush it away
i need to get right into your face okay
land hoe oh land ho that's worth two
points i feel like that deck boy is
being very judgmental captain i don't
know
i will not have infighting amongst my
crew it would be untowards
captain he's trying to infight with me
are you trying to infight with him
he's trying to start an infight by
saying the word infight a lot i didn't
even say it until this is very untowards
i will deduct points from the very next
person who fights inwardly uh what about
fighting outwardly just curiosity
i will also i might add points for that
i might there's that's fighting for
people outside of the crew and i think
that's good piracy well if there's
anything
good good piracy well he's trying to
fight me inwardly you see this is that
an inward fight wade
very inward that felt pretty inward
no you're in fighting with me now that's
his point deduction arguing with the
captain bold of you very untoward no
matter what happened i would never argue
with the captain i am aware and i
appreciate well he asked me a question i
was answering i don't know if that's
fighting sounds like you're still in
fight certainly it certainly sounds like
you're still fighting actually in the
middle debating uh captain don't worry i
shall craft an anchor
thank you actually with the sail we can
push ourselves towards
permanently
captain i present you
with two watermelons
that's exactly what we needed
where did you put him
in front of you where you were standing
i see nothing
captain now he's lying to you to try and
earn points in a cheating
hey on the bright side captain where are
you i've got you another present what is
it you know what i'm down to this rock
where it's probably sturdier if you are
in need i have
half of the watermelon yes that you gave
to me as a gift
you have it back sir
ah no i don't need it i did find these
seeds which are more important they are
you did find those seeds
that sounds like you deserve points
you're right actually i think you're
right i did find them on a rock it was
very miraculous i'll give myself three
modest points
i do i'll give myself two more perfect
excellent
perfect
perfect captain look what else you found
where are you
ah the cut of your jib is getting
sharper
captain that sounds dangerous sounds
like you could use it captain while
you're down there look what else you
found
pineapple sees oh i'm full
allow me your steed to carry them back
would you need a lift back
my legs aren't tired i think i do
oh allow
our food chest
is full
i cannot currently craft any more
edibles because we are quite full don't
worry i can humbly eat half of what
you've made well well this is really
oh
oh they're making the captain fight the
shark off all by himself that is the
response i wouldn't want to steal the
captain's glory i appreciate that
are you saying the captain can't handle
it himself oh sounds like it i found the
watermelon i found watermelon
another discovery by his captaincy i i
found those but i thought you might
enjoy discovering them yourself thank
you how about you hey why don't uh bob
you share a watermelon with the captain
i think you've earned it oh that sounds
uh seductive
it might be
i don't want to be untowards but uh they
say
watermelons are libidinous
lipids
oh let me just say this captain oh yeah
i've heard it on the wind worry not
where the captain hears those things
when you wear the hat you'll know
you'll know oh i don't think i will ever
captain he presumed
no presumpting
very
untowards um how are we feeling about
the island you want to go underneath it
or there's metal right here oh he's
going watch out
we should do i think a little metal
harvesting
all right good call good call i
agree thank you captain watch out wait
it's coming for you again now
it's okay captain nothing can get
between me and what's for the crew
so brave so brave captain i have found
what can only be described as an utter
trove
of resources for our brave crew a trove
you say
an an absolute trove no other word would
come close oh
incredible work oh i'm one bite away
from death now i worry slightly
no excuses of a coward
[Laughter]
no you might be right i have already
died once for this crew captain and i
would be happy to die again
by all means then help yourself ah that
sounds like infighting to me yes in
fighting indeed no i'm encouraging he's
in he's been fighting me to uh to die to
the shark captain that's why would you
want very exactly uh
encouraging his bravery
oh sure sure now i don't know what to
believe
incoming
i have a spear anymore your
your uh
your stuff is harvestable ah thank you
i've repaired the ship captain update
excellent update still needing planks
only been asking for a while fellaini
lengths come from the ocean this idiot
captain i don't know if he can i've used
all of them either repairing building or
refueling i don't know if this one has
the wit and wisdom to hang on not much
wit or wisdom no i think you're right my
written wisdom might be beyond this crew
hmm
it's a beautiful we should set sail sir
what do you think ah good suggestion all
in favor yes aye
yes
uh we don't say i on this show
in the affirmative vice president
for this crew
yes
i don't have a a hook or anything i'm
really
uh he sucks dick captain ah he does what
does he
that's right
hey uh
look at his shirt captain he thinks he's
number one above you even oh my goodness
then he gets one point if he thinks he's
so good take that
wait how
merely a crafted deception hmm
is nothing but a liar
yeah wait a minute why is your shirt say
six but your name says seven because my
shirt is six and i am one i gave you six
points i'm deducting seven this is
ridiculous don't make me think about
numbers again a brave and accurate
decision yes thank you hi captain yes
yeah hold a captain your horticulture is
harvestable ah good call thank you for
the reminder hurry hurry happily and
hank these hungry
hollow hippos
yes good i'm listening i'm engaged i'm
enthralled
huck them into your hopper ah good
finish
excellent finish perhaps those
harvesting nets would be good to get up
soon hmm i say we put into a vote
harvest nets i or yes
[Laughter]
or i what do you vote captain motion
right
[Laughter]
yes yes it's true it's true
higher yes it's
incomprehensibly true the weight of this
hat weighs heavily on my brain
i'm gonna keep my point distribution now
close to the chest i feel like i'm being
you know just coddled at the moment and
i i feel like you might be trying to
manipulate me do you mean we're so close
in points lando
good call good call good call
gonna say port but we don't talk like
that around here no no no no no no no
that would that would not be incorrect
would it be correct sea turtles could be
christian turtles sea turtles
wow
can we kill them we eat him can we eat
him
yeah
nope nope nope
how brave he is decoration only i would
have liked to have eaten turtle captain
oh i wish you would have gotten one okay
i'm gonna type some things on my
keyboard now hmm
i thought i'd get points for honesty not
gonna lie well you don't know what you
got i just typed in things i'm keeping
it close to my channel
the ability of you to do math captain
i'm confident i have a chance i am going
to type more i'm not sure
[Laughter]
incredible
outstanding work thank you captain
that's all i do this all for you because
i love you very deeply oh that's too
personal i did
we're not there yet i love you very
deeply on a totally normal in a totally
cool way it's fine and cool that does
feel don't worry about it cool it's very
cool feels very cool you know now that
you say it in that way we learned a
table yeah i just don't use tables well
now we know our captain what he can or
can't use yes
how dare you could do that how dare i
damn me damn you captain have points
please punish me
bro
punish me um
uh i'm not going to punish you come on
captain
maybe i should construct a punishment
chamber i'm going to build a very
special captain's thing and you two
don't look captain you've made such a
brilliant
navigation maneuver look at all these
barrels
and there's another there's a raft ahead
as well a corporal brown nose bob your
nose is very brown you might want to
wash it off merely informing the captain
of our situation and that this is
brilliant maneuver paid off perfectly
i'm merely letting you know that the
amount of brown
allowing barrels to pass us by
i'm trying to figure out how to make
these harvesting nets uh probably with
your hands i did commission those many
an age ago and they're not here you just
reminded me of your failure i will now
rotate us towards the island
then how many planks do you need sir i
have we go through a lot between
the the smelting and the cooking yeah we
need a solar harvester eventually yeah
i've i've done the research sir i need
but i need only find the resources to
craft the thingy ah yes the glass i see
sand we need to research a circuit board
i have one copper ingot cooking a
circuit board man we are getting ahead
this is so fast
oh wait you know what
uh we need to stop putting [ __ ] in the
smelter
we need copper for the we need glass and
i could make a solar water harvester
here i've got a glass on me here take it
i need two more glasses so please only
smelt glasses for the next two smelt
cycles that'll be only you smelting then
because i do not have any sand captain
what have you made over here i said not
to look at the captain's constructions
that was very clear oh you were clear
i'm sorry to be fair i was staring in
that direction when it appeared
misled by the deckhand here i did not
mean to offend you captain that's all
right it's all right the captain is very
forgiving
forgiving actually kicking your ass
right now would be in a pirate honey
like that yeah that's not going to push
you off the middle of the night
captain's not even going to know
the height of your own stupidity huh
what do you do about
that bring it in just despite you
captain we've arrived lando and we have
we have and i am almost done with my
mysterious and very complicated captains
very cool and mysterious captain i love
it yes
all right so wade i need you to come
here and i need you to uh think about
something
won't you go in that box
don't you go in the the
look at the captain's inspiration
chamber that i've built for you
and i want you to just uh think about
what's going on in there and you're
gonna stay in there i don't wanna stay
in there for about a while i'll take
care of this i'm not an armed crew
member i'm uh
you're not an armed crew member
is it any concern that i might starve to
death and or dehydrate while i'm in it's
just five minutes you can handle it to
learn your lesson
captain we're yes blowing away from the
island somehow despite your uh very
adapt navigating
interesting you are correct i see
captain your wisdom all right okay you
can come out because we need to we need
help
oh
yeah okay
we seem to be out of wood we need so
much more wood
they should have been in charge of like
if only
before we dock we might need more planks
listen uh there's a time for blame and
there's a time for uh crisis management
uh we need that island and we need a
paddle and uh i need two more planks hey
hey you know i've been pretty hard on
you but uh i think maybe captain is the
problem here
i can't hear has been oh he's husband
more plagues here you go captain thank
you thank you very prompt very prompt
all right and paddle and watch your
heroic captain use his mighty arms to uh
rescue us from certain doom
i threw it in the ocean
they call me captain competition how how
did you uh commit such an act of
awesomeness it's in my blood oh the
paddles are crazy
stupidity uh what wow what i was
thinking about myself
yes yes yes
very good very good
don't worry captain i shall go sure all
right thank you
listen i want you all to know that the
captain is going to eat this watermelon
because the captain is hungry and
thirsty and deserves it you two will get
watermelon deserves it more i'm going to
give myself some points
literally thing you deserve captain it's
what's coming for you mm-hmm
i see that's very um ominous yeah then i
have to be honest i don't
i appreciate an errand of omninity
because uh
it keeps people on their toes on a
monday
that's a big word captain that's like a
10 word ah then that sounds like it's
worth 10 points to me 10 points captain
don't you deserve more than that oh i do
but you know wow what's the harm
um dear crewmate do you have an axe only
the captain has been willed i have an
axe then let me ask you something oh my
god
oh you're drifting crew crew
captain
are you leaving us no no i wouldn't do
that i'm a good captain i would never do
that i love my crew captain please let
me aboard ah
yeah uh your glass is done oh excellent
thank you i can now craft a solar water
purifier
wow excellent and stuff that is
wonderful
it is excellent truly revolutionary i'm
gonna leave this paddle here and i'm
going to use my axe to go harvest those
trees yeah hoarder captain your
horticulture is hoarder already i will
be there in a moment i'm
horticulturizing the trees on this
island i'm just gonna pick this
up captain i am standing a watch for you
thank you
don't worry sir
why would i be worried one of the crew
like this
what could go wrong
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're ready for you captain has returned
give me a status report
uh good
good i love that
that's a good status report on the
ground at your feet excellent
excellent return of battle does anybody
need to go in the box it's inspirational
captain i would like to enjoy some time
into a box you go enjoy time in that box
you've earned it i would enjoy that very
much
hey wade i know you've been working hard
have a coconut
thank you captain you're welcome oh my
god captain this sign
oh you know what actually wait this is
look at all these new things we've
learned to do yeah this sign is so
enlightening i feel like i'm
my voice is like this now all right you
know what apparently i don't have a
hallway one anymore so just i'll just go
just [ __ ] me then hmm i like your sign
it's a good sign thank you thank you
i feel inspired and also like i'm dying
of hunger ah well you need a coconut
here
oh yes
all right there's a raft over on the
right i'm gonna angle us towards don't
worry captain i'm on top of the fishing
now
thank you now that i'm so nourished by
your nuts i will be a master fisher yes
uh i don't see any uh collector nets i i
remember ordering those many many a moon
ago like someone was ordered to
construct those captain i feel almost
collecting nets are being crafted now
captain
good good late better late than never
i'm always late captain hmm they're not
done yet captain i would keep a weather
eye brace for impact
oh gosh you'll go captain i will risk my
life good work excellent work can we
steal that oh the the raft is sinking
sir yes
hey look captain nets
oh he's twisting down with the ship no
we just twisted it
captain
oh
oh dear
captain may i come aboard yes permission
to come aboard now yes
permission to board yes
oh thank you captain
captain don't live without me i'm
harvesting dead shark that i murdered
captain okay coming back
it's pretty impressive and moving out
that's pretty good even bob is impressed
he just killed a shark that is worth
some points that is well done pretty
cool captain that's
pretty cool well i'll give you a point
for admitting is cool but not as many
points as we got just and fair as always
ah thank you if only there was a time
when we could uh experience this point
giving any time people wanted
that would be truly a delight but how
would that be possible oh
i don't know maybe there's a mysterious
link buried in the description below
maybe the x marks the spot of just some
secret location where people could
experience this glorious content at any
moment captain's going in the box for a
moment captain needs to think don't
forget your kleenex and uh lotion
captain i'll take charge while you're in
the box sir don't worry everything will
be fine
did you hear that
you dumb [ __ ] you just made me first
mate because he knows i'm the good one
but you're calling the captain a dumb
[ __ ] and i was going to go
a dumb [ __ ]
you that [ __ ] he likes me better
that's report all is well captain
nothing to worry about that's great
captain's done with captain's private
business
captain uh update post box update yes
thank you uh oh sorry that was true
the nets are still not finished so it's
crazy that there's some nets here i'm
not sure where they came from almost
like i've been working on it i seem to
remember you ordering yeah like a whole
like all over i can read the room here i
can see that you were impatient with uh
wade's slowness so you took it upon
yourself to make these collectors
no
such initiative shall not go unrewarded
yeah thank you captain yes you're
welcome whatever small token you choose
to dole out i appreciate it very deeply
it's just for you that sounds like
inviting that means oh my goodness
whispered you couldn't hear it i could
actually the whispering gag only works
when i do it you dumb [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] you [ __ ] idiot
oh captain i love you so much oh i love
you too
i love the rules of the sea i love you
almost as much as i love my fellow
crewmates we're like brothers really
i would die for him all right [ __ ]
push you off in the middle i'm still
gonna kill you in the middle of the
night captain's not even gonna have any
idea who's in that package i get to take
credit for that captain i've researched
how to make a candlestick for you well
done
excellent work
thank you very much
you're not even gonna fight your healers
are born you're gonna make me into one
it's kind of not even fun if you don't
even fight back
delicious watermelon bad news lad we
only got one seed back from the
watermelon
only one more harvest captain i am
currently in the middle of placing two
additional harvest nets me placing them
now
wow somebody is very boastful captain
that's the humble member of the pirates
one
oh no no pirates are boastful
pirates are boastful he's he's not wrong
about that uh we've made it
made it to this wonderful island our
future's here gentlemen
our future's here but i'm with you sir
i think with this island and our future
in play it's time to pick another
captain i'm going to pass the torch on
i'm going to let
the next generation take charge and in
tallying the points how oh god
oh good luck captain
ah here we go and tallying the points
hold on oh my god this is gonna take a
bit the captain's going in the captain's
box no one go in the captain's box
hold on no sense of dude any work until
we know what's gonna happen i suppose
i'm just hanging out i guess
i'm going to eat all of the food yet
don't forget captain i have killed two
sharks you have killed two sharks yes
in a i humbly take credit for them guys
this is
i just have to marvel at how close this
actually got because i completely lost
track the score is 43-42
and i don't know how the hell it got
that close
but i have the captain is emerging from
the captain's box
the new captain
i shall give the ceremonial captain's
package to
and the winner wait where where are you
i'm there i'm here all right well it
doesn't matter because it was
a bob
you're the new captain congratulations
revelation consider me shocked it was
43-42 my goodness the amount of shock i
have it was literally if you had done
one more thing you would have been
captain but only i'd been given credit
for one more of my accomplishments
[Laughter]
i might have stood a chance
yes it was close but alas uh yeah so
listen
now that i'm in charge
it would be a little different okay
uh in what way captain
uh no you don't have to call me captain
it's all right we're all friends here
okay all right we're just we're just a
couple of bros just you know boat
boating around on the deep blue sea you
know that sounds good bro
why do i hear
whoa
oh i hear ominous jaws like music is
what i was gonna say
uh probably because of the shark yeah
probably hey man it's okay we're all
right yeah why do i why do i get a bad
feeling about it we're chilling man no
we're just gonna hang out
have some good vibes and you know just
just ocean it up a little bit you know
you know yeah
that's good bro captain bruh
all right well
i'm gonna go hang out in my captain box
for a minute
uh new captain the next hour passed as
such this box is only for the captain oh
god
that's gonna be one of like the main
rule situation okay that's very good got
it but uh
you know you guys just uh just take care
of it you know and then uh
we're just bowing around a little bit
maybe maybe get the stuff off this
island i don't know maybe make sure
there's food in the food chest so nobody
gets uh
angry or anything
of course your tyrant ship
okay
that's funny jokes funny jokes call me
call me that
what would you like see what happens
[Music]
you